député du sud également membre du
mouvement indépendantiste martiniquais
jean philippe miller est dans ce sens qu
a dit ce matin bonjour bonjour bonjour à
tous les auditeurs
geof des mineurs et patriotes qui font
l'actualité politique du moment mercredi
prochain après de même il y aura cette
conférence de presse d'un groupe de
réflexion démis contents du
fonctionnement actuel du parti on y
reviendra
avant-hier vous étiez réunion cet esprit
sur votre activité de parlementaire et
jeudi jeudi dernier alfred marie-jeanne
réunion chez l'habitant augmenter ce que
le mime est à un tournant crucial de son
existence
peut-être l'avenir nous le dira en tout
cas la multiplicité des réunions n'est
pas forcément un indicateur de malaise
je rappelle que faut pas confondre les
choses allaient réunion du dernier
vendredi du mois du mime et la réunion
de samedi au saint-esprit qui est une
union de comptes rendus dans mon
activité de parlementaires etc du
réunion là ne sont pas du tout un
compact et absolument mais c'est
l'occasion de rencontrer des militants
et d'entendre par-ci par-là certain
nombre de choses notamment samedi
dernier au saint-esprit
ces militants qui sont désabusés par
cette situation alfred marie jeanne qui
parle de traîtrise de non retour de
réconciliation inenvisageable avec vous
un possible dit il et samedi des
militants historiques qui vous disent de
créer votre courant voire de partir ce
qu'elle ferait de marie jeanne a dit
également jeudi soir au goût morne on
verra bien pour l'instant je suis membre
du mime
je suis d'ailleurs le seul parlementaire
du mime et je rappelle tout simplement
ce qu'il faut il que je n'ai jamais
entendre que vous êtes gentil est
tributaire financier de ce mouvement
indépendantiste martina c'est vous qui a
interprété mais peut-être que c'est
hélas le constat qu'on peut faire moi je
veux souhaiter qu'on ait davantage de
députés c'était possible aujourd'hui je
suis membre du mou
je n'ai jamais travaillé et je n'ai
jamais dévié des fondamentaux du mime
c'est ce qui est important sur sur
nombre de dossiers sur la lf-a le
dossier al biomasse moi je n'ai pas voté
aux élections présidentielles pour le
pour emmanuel macron par exemple je suis
resté fidèle aux principes qui ont érigé
ce parti politique là j'ai fini leur
puisque nous sommes là entre nous en
petite et imiter est ce que vous y
croyez vraiment jean-philippe milord
leader du mime à qu au moyen terme
je ne cherche pas de manière
obsessionnelle à être leader je pense
tout simplement avoir une pierre
apportée à l'édifice de la martinique
et c'est vraiment ce qui me motive c'est
ce qui me donne l'énergie de me battre
pour mon peuple pour mon pays et surtout
pour laisser aux générations à venir
un capital qu'ils soient un peu plus
satisfaisant que ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
ça veut dire quoi ça il faut laisser le
martinique en meilleur état
en mai et à la pollution générale de
votre mouvement politique
ben maimon mouvement politique si je
fais partie d'un groupe c'est toujours
pour améliorer les choses pour surtout
faire preuve d'une meilleure exemplarité
je considère que nous les adultes et les
politiques d'une manière générale ils
doivent faire preuve d'exemplarité
doivent dans à travers toutes leurs
interventions à l'aide un esprit
d'apaisement l'apaisement ça ne signifie
pas qu'on n'ait pas de conviction qu'on
soit pas déterminé mais on n'a pas à
sombrer dans des querelles dans des
camps se sait c'est la réponse du berger
samedi à la bergère le la veille n'y
voyait pas de réponse simplement
l'expression d'une pensée d'une
conviction profonde bien il y aura ce
groupe de réflexion qui s'exprimera on
va reprendre les termes exprimé est
prononcée par ses membres ce groupe de
réflexion qui s'exprimera à l'extérieur
du parti car n'obtenant pas de réponse à
la terreur un parti qui apprend t-on ne
disposerait pas de statut rythmant par
exemple la tenue d'assemblées générales
à recomposition du comité national
renouvellement de ses membres et encore
pour gérer des situations délicates
comme cette crise que traverse le
mouvement indépendantiste martiniquais
aujourd'hui vous attendez quoi de cette
qu'on fait
de presse je verrai bien j'attends
sereinement ce qui va sortir j'espère
que l'état d'esprit ne sera pas un état
d'esprit de réponse à certaines
agressions par des agressions je dois
dire je ne suis pas membre de ce groupe
de réflexion
laval a précisé puisque lorsqu'on les
interroge ses membres de ce groupe de
réflexion et disney que les élus
actuellement fonctions à la collectivité
territoriale de martinique ne sont pas
dans ce groupe de réflexion pour ne pas
ajouter d'autres frictions voilà moi
j'ai toujours privilégié la solution de
régler les problèmes en interne lorsque
ces problèmes font surface
malheureusement je comprends aussi la
démarche de ce groupe de réflexion là
parce qu'à partir du moment où il ya des
des courriers qui sont adressés à des
demandes qui sont adressés en interne et
que ces demandes-là n'obtiennent aucune
réponse ni favorable ni défavorable
aucune réponse je crois je comprends que
pour essayer de sauver le mime que ces
militants historiques ces anciens de la
première heure mais cherche à poser à
poser les questions ouvertement et à
intervalles et par d'autres biais je
finirai un député vous êtes de ceux qui
contribuent à la rédaction de textes de
loi vous savez ce que c'est que ce
statut pour régir une association
qu'elle soit associatif politique ou
autre ça ne vous a pas interpellé plus
tôt qui qu'il n'y ait pas de statut
comme l'annoncé par exemple secrétaire
général à l'organisation lors d'une
rencontre qui s'est tenue au lamentin il
ya quelques temps nous avons interpellé
six lits à les statuts du mime
heureusement qui a ses statuts alors
pourquoi les gens enterrent général a
dit que ça n'existe pas je ne sais pas
je n'étais pas présent à cette réunion
je ne la supprime la la responsabilité
la paternité de mes propos passés de
tous mes camarades il y a des statuts au
mime et je considère qu'il faut
respecter ce statut là en toute
circonstance parce que du respect de ses
statuts et puis à voir par exemple des
aides publiques
jean-philippe ni leur réunion bilan de 2
par l'autre des statuts existe ne serait
ce que pour prononcer une exclusion il
faut respecter les statuts
quel que soit le groupe que les soit
statut soit écrit de manière formelle ou
informelle
il ya des règles de fonctionnement on ne
peut pas modifier à vau l'eau
les règles de fonctionnement parce que
sinon le jeu n'est pas clair la réunion
donc le 2 bilan de nand activités
parlementaires aventis est inscrit
devant des centaines de personnes on va
pas rentrer dans la querelle des
chiffres parce qu'on risque de présence
forcément d'accord mais monsieur ni l'or
ça ressemblait plutôt au coup d'envoi
d'une série de rencontres pour préparer
la campagne pour 2021 la collectivité
territoriale de martinique
ce n'était pas du tout dans cet objectif
que cette réunion est que les autres
réunions que celles qui suivront dans
toute la martinique ont été prévus je
considère à 400k élus du peuple
martiniquais
je me dois de rendre des comptes au
peuple martiniquais ce n'est pas une
première
ce puits 2015 par exemple j'ai commencé
j'ai compris j'ai commencé ce type de
réunion parce que le peuple a le droit
de savoir et non seulement c'est un
exercice de transmission c'est un
exercice peut être pour essayer de
susciter l'intérêt notamment des plus
jeunes d'entre nous qui au regard du
spectacle que qui est proposé
aujourd'hui n'ont pas beaucoup de
motivation un pouce lancer dans le
combat politique est un combat politique
noble mais c'est aussi l'opportunité
pour moi et le du peuple martiniquais de
prendre la tension de recevoir des
conseils devraient en recevoir des
encouragements de vendée mais oui de
compter ses forces parce que c'est
important si dans dans lorsque l'on est
attaqué publiquement et de manière pas
toujours saine il faut le dire
de manière pas toujours correctes c'est
bon il faut le dire de recevoir le
soutien populaire le soutien des gens
qui font qu'ils font bien la différence
et qui qui ont une capacité d'analysé
que beaucoup d'hommes politiques n'ont
pas donc oui c'est important de compter
ses forces
parce que l'on verra pour 2021 mais si
on verra si ça doit porter des fruits on
va pas cracher dessus
mais le travail à faire aujourd'hui les
au delà de 2021
il est de se battre pour que la
martinique puisse offrir une autre image
à l'extérieur mais qu'elle puisse
s'offrir aussi une autre image jamais
tranché dans le vif
c'est la meilleure façon d'avancer pour
vous c'est ce qu'on vous reproche bien
entendu personnellement samedi dernier
jean philippe à cadran responsabilités
il trop molle il trop mollement un bain
sous tension par tonne sa maladie si
c'est mon handicap assez saine car il
n'y a plus de 600 ha dans l'union qui a
fait sa venue porter des réponses bien
précise même si vous aviez précise en
début de réunion que vous n'êtes pas là
pour faire des polémiques nous faire le
buzz
là on en a envie devant les gens qui y
loge qui prend ses responsabilités qui
tranchent parlant là vous vous devriez
déceler à travers mon attitude à travers
mon comportement
une prise d'y terminer de
responsabilités pour prendre ses
responsabilités on n'a pas besoin d'être
agressif on n'a pas besoin de menacer
les gens on doit assumer ses
responsabilités en toute intelligence et
c'est je crois que c'est ce qu'est en
train de se faire et le soutien
populaire massif que je reçois me
confortent dans cette démarche du maire
si j'en finis leur rappelle que vous
êtes membre du parti du mouvement
indépendantiste martiniquais et député
de la martinique merci bonne journée
merci
[Musique]